while Smith and Carlos's silent protest
was the inspiration behind the recent
take Annie campaign by NFL players here
in America started when a former San
Francisco 49ers quarterback Colin
Kaepernick knelt during the national
anthem and he said he was challenging
racial injustice and police brutality
President Donald Trump has repeatedly
lashed out against NFL players who
joined the protests in September he
tweeted here the issue of kneeling has
nothing to do with race it's about
respect for our country flag and
national anthem the NFL must respect us
well here in Germany soccer players
showed their solidarity with the NFL
demonstrators Berlin Herto team took a
knee before a Bundesliga match in
October to protest against racism in
sports and I'm joined by the man who
inspired those gestures of protest a man
who stood on the podium in 1968 with his
fist race Tommie Smith Tommy thank you
so much for joining us on our program
today pleasures thank you great to have
you take us back as I know you've had to
do so many times to that day October
16th 1968 why did you decide to raise
the fist I Tommy Smith from a young
child one of 12 I have 11 siblings Tommy
always wanted to do something that would
move things forward whether it's a rock
in the fields that I worked in whether
it was a changing a wire on the fence
anything that I could do to make change
forward to make things better and I was
blessed to move forward enough strong
enough to have a platform to help human
nature the Olympic project for Human
Rights not only not the only per project
for black rights that's inclusive of
course and because I was black because
you saw a black fist people associated
that with power right people you're
right
but also they said black power which is
representative of the black fist which
means power so that's fine but it was my
platform it was not a platform of hate
and another was not a platform or a ver
moistfull saying it was a cry for
freedom coming from a young 24 year old
lips
need to survive with that war did you
know that cry for freedom was going to
be so controversial when you took to the
podium I hope people understand that
anytime you cry for something that means
justice has not been done enough to make
it even a morality to be thankful for
really at least most things that morsel
should be thankful no I did not answer
your question quickly but they did move
to a point where others begin to see and
still seeing by the way even in
athletics that a need for them to become
involved on a proactive level is mighty
for it justifies the illegality of
stupidity and the need to for them to
get involved come on folks involve
yourself still today an important
message now a lot of people don't know
that you've received an incredible
backlash after that gesture tell us what
happened and how bad things got you know
young it was a backlash even before I
got to Mexico City because this was not
a superlative moment or deal it was
defiantly justified in the meetings of
young black athletes who were hopefuls
for the Olympic movement and because I
was on the platform to start this at San
Jose State University a year before the
Olympic Games it was organized with
finality justification and pride and it
was decided about all the athletes that
there would not be a boycott but each
athlete would represent himself
according to how he felt a country
represented him they gave them the
Liberty to move freely in the Olympic
statues there while the game was taking
place and Tommy Smith who started the
movement finished a movement I want to
ask you about another man on the podium
that was the silver medalist Peter
Norman he also took part in this protest
how significant was that well Peter made
it it's significant in his own right by
becoming the silver medalist Peters for
my story is most people know and his
whole family had a history of working
for freedom and even in his country so
he it wasn't so much that Peter backed
Tommie Smith and John Carlos Peter only
showed his understanding his belief also
in human rights so give him his pride in
his own feeling not Thomas mr. John
Carlos involvement with him tell me I
want to ask you as we were sitting here
and you were looking at this image
behind you yes that isn't big enough
when you look at it what do you feel I
feel sad for the kid up there doing that
because I know he didn't want to do it
but he had to do it because he was put
there through divine spirit to do what
the one else could do because of there
was his platform and everyone noticed
I'm sure that it was a silent gesture so
each person who viewed that I hopefully
saw themselves and wondered why I did
quite am I doing this or what am i doing
this for I know what Tommy Smith did it
for what are the young people looking at
it now what does that mean to them it's
a positive and I know it's a positive
because he's been revealed to me through
many many cases such as : such as the
football players a need to move forward
proactively without the the danger of
needing it later this is a battle you've
continued continued and the reason
you're in Germany is you're receiving
The Dresden Peace Prize yes indeed when
you look and congratulations to you on
that when you look at the situation
today do you feel satisfaction do you
feel frustration I feel a moral pride in
people that want to find and create and
move forward progressively and this
takes thoughtful conversation not
rapping but confining your thought in
two words to make people understand that
I'm for real I want to move forward yeah
we know this war I just came from a
seated visitor that were destroyed by a
war I'm talking about peace of talk this
is a new age this is a new date I think
conversation not only between brothers
and sisters or uncles and aunts or dads
but I mean conversation of nations part
of that conversation even though we've
come a long way as the
fact that we've seen the black lives
matter movement take off in the US we
saw on the wall behind us the image of
Colin Kaepernick taking a knee in the
criticism he's received also LeBron
James getting into a Twitter battle with
the US president when you look at that
how far have we come we've come a long
ways verbally a long ways verbally
physically we come in further as far we
got to keep both of them as close to
pasta close together as possible and
that's why the athletes are so important
young folks see athletes as as role
models they see athletes as actors and I
think the athletes o or a great
opinionated due to the people who are
watching them and trying to take on a
role such as them so athletes you're
great why don't we move gratefully
forward so these young folks can do
better than we're doing to try to create
a world from blowing up are you hopeful
when you see movements like the one that
was started by Colin Kaepernick are you
hopeful for the future of athletes and a
statements that they're making in sports
yeah I think it's gonna keep moving in
my hope is that conversation will will
bend the rules to the betterment of a
factual getting together rowing you know
it's a grassroot now and I think is kind
of blossomed to a beautiful role someday
but we still have to tilt it we still
have to tell it you don't tell a rose
it's not going to survive that's a great
note to end our conversation on Tommie
Smith congratulations to you on The
Dresden Peace Prize and thank you again
for joining us one of my pleasure